okay good so if you look at a block
basically a block is a
collection of transactions where you see
here this transaction has two inputs and
there are two signatures authorizing the
expenditure of those inputs this
transaction has three inputs and so on
and so forth we saw that every block has
about a thousand transactions in it so a
thousand transactions are added to the
blockchain as a whole
um the size of a block you know is uh
you know between one one megabytes um
and in more modern versions it's even
bigger and we said that every that a new
block is added about every 10 minutes so
that's a lot of data that's being added
to the blockchain network every 10
minutes we're adding an entire block and
so as you can imagine the size of a
blockchain kind of grows and grows and
grows and grows and grows
over time and in fact if you look at it
at its growth kind of its growth is
linear over time we're adding a fixed
amount every 10 minutes and
you know when i looked last in in uh
september
uh 2018 the size of the blockchain was
already 182 gigabytes the entire
blockchain 182 gigabytes so if you're
going to replicate the blockchain you
basically have to allocate 102 gigabytes
of space on your disk and then you have
the entire blockchain written down and
as you can imagine it's going to
continue to grow linearly
hopefully in perpetuity
and that basically uh
you know will allow people to continue
sending funds to one another using the
bitcoins that they currently own
okay so the interesting properties of
these currencies uh which is kind of
fascinating is again no one can take
your crypto assets the only way that
bitcoin or crypto assets in general can
be spent or transferred is by issuing
issuing a digital signature on
the transaction authorizing the
expenditure or transfer of those funds
if someone doesn't have your secret key
they cannot spend funds on your behalf
so the only way they can someone can
take your funds is if you give them your
secret key or if you give them a
signature that allows them to spend
funds on your behalf yeah so that's kind
of reassuring in that
you know again if once you own a certain
crypto asset no one can take it away
from you unless you give them the secret
key
this is quite different from fiat
currencies where for example you know if
you have
i don't know if you have a bond of some
sort
some entity can come and say well these
bonds are now invalid and you can no
longer redeem your funds
um however the other property is we have
this liveness property which says
basically no one can prevent you from
spending your funds yeah so liveness
means that the system will never get
stuck and then in fact no one can
prevent honest users from posting new
transactions to the blockchain so even
if someone doesn't want you to uh post
transactions to the blockchain you can
always find a miner that
will will help you post transactions you
can even potentially try to post
transactions yourself um so in principle
in the design of the system no one can
prevent you from spending your own funds
and finally the blockchain it's
important to remember that the
blockchain is completely public not only
is it public it's replicated across many
many many users so everyone can see
what's on the blockchain everyone can
verify that all the transactions on the
blockchain are valid in particular all
the block all transaction data is
publicly available we're going to talk
about this in much more detail actually
later on